yes thanks for doing our show and I also
want to say this we would love to have
you back yes well first of all before we
continue okay we go [ __ ] I already know
what this traitorous [ __ ] right here
okay
him and I talked for six nine months a
year talking about we're gonna do a
podcast we're gonna do we also went to
all new variety together we went and met
with somebody and then he's in here like
I'm gonna make this room into a podcast
room I'm like oh this is great
this is great hey Bobby all of a sudden
he's like oh yeah I'm doing a podcast
with my girlfriend I was like you bros
before hoes because traitorous [ __ ] left
our fire team on destiny Wow
and then you did this to me what really
glad to be here no cleric listen when
you guys first talked about doing the
podcast I facilitated I told him I will
set up the whole room for you in Eric I
will do whatever I will I never [ __ ]
ask them to do this as a matter of fact
I just like it no I pushed for you and I
kept reminding him he had to do one with
you but you know he doesn't remember
hearing your conversation when he told
you that he was doing it with me I heard
you I heard I've been with a Filipino I
know what you did to him yeah with some
adobo
I said it punch it no I baited them in
you're right but you know what I mean I
don't regret the decision I and you know
what and I don't know I'm gonna say this
[ __ ] okay good I really love you
I really do as a friend I really love
you but I love the situation and you're
doing great in life and you're gonna do
even greater things and I'm proud to
know you and let's end this [ __ ]
thing how about this those are hot Cass
is like your relationship they do it at
first and it worked out okay people did
two or three podcasts well what's
stopping you from what we were supposed
to do that making a murderer one we have
to still do that I still have a lot a
lot of yeah that you know issues you
know wish it because we have this
facility now we should try to facilitate
you mean your second bedroom yes go up
to you put a microphone in it it becomes
a facility by the Magnum condom doesn't
mean you have a big dick did you have a
question we don't we do a question
whether the
[Music]